they are working this great difficulty
they are being constantly shelled russia
is constantly breaking the deal the
corridors that we are opening in reality
are being shelled
people don't feel safe especially when
it comes to mariupol where the world
scale humanitarian catastrophe has been
ongoing for more than three weeks
nato is meeting today do you feel that
nato has let ukraine down
we don't have a right to be disappointed
we don't have a right to stop our fight
and we don't have a right for emotions
that aren't helpful for all the survival
and victory over russia we obviously
understand that the forces have not been
equal from the start we talk about
russia having a big amount of weapons
what russia doesn't have and what
ukraine has is the fact that we are on
our own land where all people are
fighting whether children or adults
what nato decides or doesn't decide will
be judged by history not only by
ukrainians but by the whole civilized
world the question that is at stake
today is if evil wins if dark wins over
good or perhaps we will learn how to
live as humans to remain humans no
matter what
[Music]
what is the current status of the russia
ukrainian talks russia seems to be
talking about big picture stuff um
demilitarization potential withdrawal
nato membership but ukraine is sticking
to its guns and saying it's a ceasefire
and it's withdrawal from territories is
there any common ground
if russia wanted to find a solution we
would not have war
russia understands well that we don't
have any nazis because our legislation
strictly condemns nazism
russia understands well that it demands
what will never happen we can't concede
our territory for what
if things were like this russia i will
repeat again would never attack russia
doesn't want any talks and is pretending
that it is participating in the round
table
it makes it possible that the talks
don't succeed
russia is killing civilians and creating
a humanitarian catastrophe in ukraine is
the goal so that we never find an
agreement
if things were the opposite we would
have already found an agreement long
time ago
and now um this the european union seem
to be taking the lead when it comes to
ukraine but for you is this much more of
a global fight
we are fighting for the world we want to
live in a world where those who think
that they rule won't be able to do such
things neither to us nor to you
my ask is to support ukraine support
ukrainian people support us in our
fighting
believe me everyone will gain from it
including your leaders and your nations
peace will become a guarantee for the
safety of all of us